connect with influencers
if you want to market your business if
you want people to talk about you
one of the fastest ways to get more word
of mouth is to connect with people who
have audiences
and have them help spread the word hi
i'm evan carmichael i believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
and today i'm answering the question
from a youtube viewer love you guys
we are toybox hero wrote in to say
i'm a toy collector i have what i think
is a great idea for a home-based
business i would provide a service of
the collectors it's a web-based company
that i would run from home providing a
service it'd be very helpful the toy
collectors
how do i get the word out about my site
set up the site is easy
i've never done it before but getting
traffic is where i seem to have an issue
thanks in advance
so if you're a big toy collector
and you're part of that community and
you know other toy collectors what i
would do
is go and start talking to the people
who can influence other toy collectors
go talk to bloggers go talk to the place
that you buy
all your toys from the different stores
that you go to and get those guys on
board and even
build your system around them i would go
to
my favorite toy store wherever you're
buying most of your stuff from
if you're a collector they probably have
a good relationship with you
let them know what you're doing ask them
to be a tester
get their feedback build it around the
challenges that they're seeing in the
market
and then when you launch it they're
going to be your advocate they're going
to say hey i helped build this thing
and they can tell everybody in their
store make a list
of 10 20 30 key influencers in your
business
in your industry it could be offline
like retail stores
or it could be online with bloggers and
people who are in forums and people who
are talking about these things
and use them to help build your product
get their feedback
and build a product around them most
people
if you call them up and you're genuine
and you say you'd like 15 minutes of
their time because you'd like their
advice
and it's related to toys what they're
passionate about they're going to give
you the time
and they're going to get excited about
this project if you are and when it
launches they're going to spread the
word
if you're trying to get word of mouth
marketing it's great to build it around
your current customers but if you've got
nothing then start working
with connectors people who have a
community
instead of you going out and trying to
get people one by one by one to sign up
use these guys who already have a big
audience
and have them help build your product
from their feedback and then help spread
the word and promote it
here's a quick example i not too long
ago made a line of famous entrepreneur
trading cards
okay we had people like steve jobs and
bill gates
and donald trump and those guys on the
covers of our cards
and what i did was i connected with
famous bloggers so i connected with seth
godin
and i kept with guy kawasaki people who
were influential
in the entrepreneur space that i deal in
and had their own audiences and i asked
him who's your favorite famous
entrepreneur
and we made a card about it and all the
prophets went to support kiva which is a
charity that i support and believe in
and when the cards launched i sent it to
them and we had tim ferriss in the
four-hour work week and guys like seth
go and guy kawasaki and sent them off
the cards
and a lot of them ended up talking about
it and promoting it
so it wasn't just me permanent to my
audience it was them all saying look at
this great project that i was a part of
it's a great cause it's really cool go
check it out
and all of their audiences then came to
me to go check out the cards
and buy them so it's great to have your
own audience
and once you start building your own
community you support them like crazy
you want them to love what you do so
they go off and talk about you over
deliver like crazy to get word of mouth
going but at the very start
talk to key influencers get them
involved get their support
so that when you launch they'll help
promote you spread the word
and hopefully it'll catch like wildfire
good luck great question
for those of you watching like the video
you know the drill thumbs up below thank
you guys so much and hey i want to hear
from you you like this video you have a
comment please leave it below
it makes my day when i see those come in
and if you have a question for your
business please leave it in the comment
section below and i will make a video
response for you thank you guys i'll see
you soon